si vous êtes l'un des 7 millions
d'abonnés du réseau de téléphones
portables bouygues si vous en avez dans
votre entourage vous avez été témoin
hier du désarroi des gens privés de
téléphone on se sent complètement perdus
on a l'impression d'être coupée du monde
on a complètement oublié qu'il existe
des cabines téléphoniques au coin de la
rue on s'aperçoit aussi qu'à force de
mettre le numéro en mémoire on les
connaît plus parker bref on réalise à
quel point on est accro et dépendant
alors tout de suite premières
informations essentielles pour vous
la panne est terminée ça marche à
nouveau yvan martin et pierre bond
joseph nous sommes au coeur du problème
la panne géante connu par bouygues
telecom hier est né quelque part dans
ses ordinateurs
les causes de la panne ne sont pas
encore totalement totalement prêts si
les identifier on peut dire c'est qu'on
avait deux machines qui peuvent contre
la totalité du réseau à l 2 avec chacune
la poster de reprendre la totalité du
réseau ayant nous avons eu simultanément
ce qui est tout à fait exceptionnel une
panne sur chacune des machines
pratiquement au même moment pour
retrouver le réseau les abonnés devait
ce matin éteindre puis rallumés leur
portable mais la journée d'hier restera
dans les mémoires exemple à paris dans
cette agence de communication ça a été
l'enfer impossibilité de joindre les
clients impossibilité de faire
l'ensemble des courses distribution de
produits nous avons besoin grosses
difficultés pour organiser notre
événement dont nous avions
l'organisation aujourd'hui dans les
heures qui viennent
au total ce sont plus de 7 millions
d'utilisateurs qui ont été touchés ce
matin ils redécouvrent les joies du
téléphone et espère une compensation
entre eux va être
j'espérais quoi ce titre édifiant sa
prochaine facture
pour l'heure bouygues telecom n'évoque
pas encore de réduction mais promet d'un
geste commercial